here's the function question to 15000 X
minus 50 on X to the 4 and then they say
interestingly the domain for this is X
is greater than 50 and just keeping on
forever
usually where like in between here like
you can see down below it's like yeah
and that's understandable right it's
like that's weird what am I supposed to
do with this right we're we're very used
to we're very used to this business what
defines start what to find end you could
go okay this one here this one here
because you would say you were pointing
in your hand infinite in that direction
and you're pointing towards the 50 and I
was like yeah that's um I'll wear that
one okay so then it's like it sir
who else is gonna say was it so anyway
uh hum you can see here when we then say
for this particular guy here when you
look at something like this you're like
okay start at 50 and then go to the
right until you hit 60 that's fine right
so you get an integral for this question
well turns out it's um I think I've done
the question just up here oh yeah I
guess so yeah it's pretty small
it's 127 that's what you end up with
should you like if I'm gonna go to all
the way to infinity
yeah good job good job right so there's
there's the integral we're gonna have to
evaluate and then and that's what you
can see I've done over here on the on
the right-hand side I went and worked
out like if you recall this is where you
turn it into a log and it was like no it
actually you try and doesn't work out
for you right yeah so so this is me
going through the process of just
working on what the primitive is because
I'm like wow this is so much work on its
own I I set that aside right and then I
you know like like I mentioned before
I'm gonna have to put numbers into this
function and I'm gonna have to chuck
them in here so I'm like uh I want to
make this as simple as I possibly can
and so all all of these upsy-daisy
all the
uh what's not simple you put in more
keystrokes frozen you mean to get to
here no I'd argue this is less
keystrokes than like this you're talking
about doing that this is oh my god this
is terrible why you making things worse
so hit that's that would be nice yeah
it's dangerous okay so anyway yes I did
yeah I have to go through those lines
just just for my own sake and like I'm
looking at myself and thinking I am so
gonna get those double negatives wrong
like it's just a bit of a mess and I
actually if to make you feel better
right you did i I made mistakes and I
was like oh okay and I was like beating
my head against the wall and I was like
ah it's because actually the reason why
was I was trying to do a lot of this in
my head that some call me is that a good
thing or mouthing very good thing
I can't mix it makes it reachable ya
know it's not a closely related so
anyhow once I get my on this is my
primitive function it's the thing that
I'm gonna put my upper and lower
boundaries in whatever they happen to be
and you can see if we come back to the
original question it's like oh here's a
bit he is a boundary here's a boundary
here's about it so all of these guys are
going to get put into this guy here
so make sense so I write it once and for
all it's nice and simplifying
and yeah yes ah okay good good pickup so
you noticed because I've written it in
this form if I go back to the top here
because I've written it in this form
without thinking about a particular
question with particular boundaries I
have to write as an indefinite integral
right and you're like oh this indefinite
integral I I'm gonna end up with this
Plus this plus C right and you can't and
you can't get rid of it okay
however I then can take that primitive
and say that everything I'm about to do
I'm going to evaluate it with boundaries
it's going to be definite integrals all
the way and so when I put in like for
example here when I do when I do this
line here right you can see I've gone to
the next line you're like where do my
plus C's go you know did you notice they
disappeared right there's no there's no
plus C's here and it's kind of sneaky
the reason why I'm just gonna put this
to one side now the reason why they
disappear is because I am I am being
slightly cheap and I'll show you what's
going on here right this f of 60 capital
F of 60 I should say that's me
evaluating the primitive function at 60
so that's why you can see that's this
line in here can you see the 60 appear
here and yeah you see me evaluating it
yeah and then the other one let's color
this is f of 50 yeah and you can see it
right you can see the 50s appearing down
the bottom not to be confused with so
right color not to be confused with this
50 that 50 was there as part of the
original proof right but you can see
there's the 50 there there's a 50 there
exactly now you're like hey what's up
with the factor your plus Caesar not
there well even if I put them in they
get they get cancelled you see that
which is why indefinite integrals we
just forget about the plus C because the
posse appears twice it gets added then
it gets subtracted immediately exactly
the plus C could be anything you like
right but it's the same plus C on the
upper and the lower bounds so that's why
they always cancel only exactly
precisely so
that's how we get this answer to over 27
just bringing this back a little bigger
Part B is exactly the same because if
you have a look here I might as well
just leave that there
if you have a look at this one here
they're just saying same idea but less
than 75 so it's going to be the interval
again you start at 50 because that's the
the lowest value for which the
probability density function is defined
it's not at 50 and then you go up so we
could say for 25 that distance is 25
right sorry from 50 to 75 yeah it
doesn't yet start with you and it's all
I know it's the same right uniform yeah
so when you have a uniform distribution
you can just say you know the height you
know width just a rectangle man ball
right that's just a rectangle so length
times bread but this guy here this is
very emphatically not a nice neat
rectangle this is some garbled message
pretty nicely yeah okay we Jemaine yes
so so here is me doing the working
slightly need up Jeremy it's a cool name
it is so so let's have a look at this
right so they asked us for this
probability greater than 65 right but
you're like hold on a second if I just
say on a number line for example on a
number line my probability density
function I know it starts at 50 and it
can just keep on going right so if you
ask me for less than 60 right you can
see oh it's going to be it's going to be
this entire stretch within here this
interval right you've got a 50 on one
side you have 60 on the others yeah
you're like wait a second right then at
this point you're like us bigger than 65
see like oh there's nothing stopping me
from just going forever and ever never
right so that that's the that's how I
did it here right since that function is
going toward zero right even though you
can't put infinity into it
you can recognize the fact that it's
it's going to behave like zero okay so
therefore you get top boundary lower
boundary and then off you go you get
this value okay
alternatively and I like this way of
thinking it just ends up being slightly
more working out yeah mm-hmm no no no
yes yeah yeah Zeno's paradoxes you know
this is the practical application yeah
yeah no it's cool isn't it yeah now you
can go ahead and give it a go and show
that if you approach it the other way
you can say the total probability every
probability added up like the sum of all
those probabilities will equal one and I
know this function it exists for
anything from 50 onwards right so
therefore if I say from 50 to 65 and
then from 65 onwards that should be
everything I should have caught
everything in that right and that's why
you get a total of one and all I like
this is the thing here this is my actual
thing that I want right a little bit so
because that thing there is what I want
what I do is you can see I've subtracted
this term from both sides that's how it
ends up over here right and this guy
here this just this does turn into an
integral with a nice lower boundary nice
upper boundary and then you just
evaluate it like you did before
okay and there is some there's some fun
calculator work in here which I didn't
want to labor but you do and I
double-checked it on a computer you do
get the same answer both ways which is
nice